Well, it had to happen eventually, the frustration
from being unable to send out his screeds
and diatribes via Twitter was going to get
to former President Donald Trump.
And there's a report from The Daily Beast
that Trump is so frustrated from being unable
to send out insults on Twitter because he's
banned, that he's been writing down insults
and giving them to aides and asking them to
tweet the messages out.
This is being reported by The Daily Beast.
Sources close to Trump said to The Daily Beast
that Trump was really, really upset.
I'm so wound up about the story.
I just threw my Sharpie, the entire Liz Cheney
thing where there was a referendum within
the Republican Party about Liz Cheney and
whether she should retain her leadership role
or not.
And you might recall that Liz Cheney was one
of the 10 Republicans in the House that back
in January voted to impeach Donald Trump in
the House of Representatives, now leading
to his upcoming second impeachment trial.
And this entire time, Trump couldn't tweet.
He was desperate to tweet.
He was desperate to attack his political opponents.
And what is being reported is that Trump has,
quote, written out insults and observations,
several of them about Liz Cheney.
I assume some are about her physical appearance
because it's Trump and has resorted to suggesting
put downs for others to use or post to their
own Twitter accounts.
And I mean, this is you know, it's so ridiculous
and childish, but completely obvious that,
you know, I was thinking Trump Trump almost
seems more upset about not being able to tweet
than he is about not being president anymore.
And then I thought, well, he might actually
believe he still is the rightful president
because he believes it was supposedly stolen
by Joe Biden.
Trump seems to know he's definitely banned
from Twitter.
I have this image of Trump sitting at Mar
a Lago or wherever he is, I don't even know
with construction paper and crayons, but not
the thin crayons, the fat ones, where, like,
it's impossible to write anything coherently,
sitting there writing out insults with one
of the fat crayons in a piece of construction
paper and seeing who might be willing to tweet
it out.
I think we'll know if Trump's written screeds
are getting out on Twitter.
Like if we see Steven Miller tweet that little
Marco Rubio isn't really a patriot or something
about Ted Cruz's wife's physical appearance
will know that it's probably not really Steven
Miller tweeting.
It's probably actually Donald Trump.
And as we observed during the presidency,
this is a man, Trump, who seems to have like
a bottomless reflex or a desire to just insult
people.
It comes so naturally to him.
And a lot of it, from what we know, seems
to come from from his childhood in the way
he was raised and the relationship with his
dad not to get all all Freudian.
And it's it's really the type of pathetic
behavior that just reminds us again that this
guy never had the temperament to be president
of the United States.
And we think back to Hillary Clinton during
the debates in 2016 who said this man is temperamentally
unfit to be president.
And of course, she was completely right.
And for the last, what was it, few weeks,
I guess a month or so of Trump being on Twitter?
More than more than half, certainly.
I don't know what percentage of his tweets
were being labeled either misleading or were
restricted by Twitter for either spreading
conspiracy theories or making false claims
about elections or whatever the case may be.
And now we are seeing a real rift in the Republican
Party where you have lawmakers who want to
completely get rid of even Trump almost like
a race trump from history and get rid of his
influence.
And then you have this other side, the Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobert side, that seems
determined to keep Trump ism going to to some
degree.
And that's what led to this movement within
the Republican Party to try to remove Congresswoman
Liz Cheney and anti Trump or at least a Trump
skeptical Republican from a position of power.
It failed.
And throughout all of this, Donald Trump reportedly
very pleased with Marjorie Taylor Greene,
desperate to get somebody to tweet out the
insults that he's been coming up with.
So I don't know what else to tell you, but
Trump behaving exactly as we would expect
him
to behave.